Daniel thanks for joining us I know it
was a long night when did you get an
idea of what the Chicago Bears were
going to do with that number to pick
overall when they when they turn in the
cards when they announced a pick from
the podium
I had heard I had heard about a month
ago that that there was some chatter
about them taking true Biscay at 3:00
and so that I just tried to dig around
everybody I could around that
organization people are tied in and
everybody came back and said not
happening not happening not happening so
to me I think this is uh you know this
is kind of like the bortles thing with
Jacksonville I think Ryan pace just I
don't know if he told his wife about
this one what do you think of the pic
well I didn't I don't I don't really
like it you know to me it all comes down
to how you evaluate a man even how you
think what you do and if you think he
can be a solid starting quarterback for
you for a long time then I understand it
I just didn't quite view him in that
light and I think that you know I think
some of this in my opinion is just you
look at this quarterback class for so
long and then you start sorting these
guys out so okay you move you move these
guys around to the top of this year's
list I think you maybe lose a little bit
of a sense okay well what how could is
this group as a whole okay he's the best
of this group but how good is this group
that to me is why I didn't really see
the value who reached higher the Bears
with what they did
the Texans with what they did or Kansas
City with what they did um gosh I would
say I would say if it was any if it was
any other person in Andy Reid I would
say without question I think it was what
what the Chiefs did you know I've said
about my homes throughout this whole
process you know the only quarterback
that's ever functioned primarily out of
the structure of the offense and had
long-term success in the NFL is Brett
Favre now was he a unicorn I mean is
that a one one-time-only deal well I
don't know but now you've got him in a
building John Dorsey and with Andy Reed
who had a front row seat
for Brett Favre so if the organization
can figure this thing out with my homes
and I still think it's a two-year
process to get him on the field
he's in the perfect place but you get a
quarterback you're not asking the
quarterback to sort of fit in with your
system if you have a quarterback like
that you almost have to have a system
that fits in with him don't you yeah but
I think you know people talk about Andy
Reid and they've said how is this going
to fit you know with Alex Smith Alex
Smith truthfully could not be any more
polar opposite than then Pat mahomes
yeah and their exact opposites with the
way they played a game but I was with
coach Reid in Philadelphia when we had
Michael Vick who had a lot of success
doing stuff outside of the offense so
you know the kilcher he's pretty smart
dude now he knows how to adapt to what
he has and I think when I look at this
situation I think when you look at the
postseason Dan quarterbacks people have
debated about Joe Flacco forever right
that's that tired old argument well you
don't have to be quote unquote elite for
16 weeks we just need a guy with a high
enough ceiling you know like a
postseason pitcher they can get hot and
when it's a championship but you have to
have that high ceiling Alex Smith
doesn't have that he's going to get you
a bunch of regular season when he might
sneak out a playoff one or two but in
those you know as you go to the playoffs
there's some of those rare throws you
have to make you got to take chances you
got to be aggressive and you got to have
the tools to do it
I don't think he can get over a certain
level whereas mahomes
is feeling he can get to that level what
was the oddest pick
aside from if you think true Biscay was
the honest pick what was the second one
oh yeah I mean there was there was a
couple odd to me I thought Baltimore
where they were picking you know I know
Ozzie loves Alabama players
I don't know that Humphrey was one of
the best for Alabama players that were
available I mean if you just kind of go
off best player available I know
Jonathan Allen there were some concerned
health-wise Rueben foster some concerned
health-wise but OJ Howard was still
there I thought all those guys when you
watch Alabama play I thought they were
better football players from Arlen
Humphrey the garyun Conley taken a
lie-detector test can you remember has
that happened before when you were
working with teams did you ever have a
player take a lie-detector test
no no that's the first I'd heard of that
but in talking to some teams last night
Dan they had done
a ton of work and had got their hands on
a bunch of information or evidence
saying or ever you want to call it in
this case and they felt very confident
that nothing was going to come out of
this and so I I talked to one team that
told me look if he's there in the second
round we're taking him so you know a
little bit of a surprise with the
uncertainty publicly that he went in the
first round but these teams have a lot
more information than what we have in
the public right now what was the
smartest pick I mean okay Howard to me
when you look at Tampa Bay and what
they've done in the offseason to get OJ
Howard 19 yeah and you throw him in with
Mike Evans and now DeSean Jackson in
that mix and I think you'll see them I
mean damn it
Dalvin cook hasn't gone there's a chance
and as your Tampa Bay you don't know
what's going on with Doug Martin there's
always some trades early in the second
round because teams have had all night
to look and see what's still available
you imagine if they somehow through
Dalvin cook in there as well but I don't
understand this though Daniel if Delvin
Cook has character issues as a first
rounder potential first render he still
has character issues as a second or
third rounder here Daniel no no I
thought the way it works Dan OS
[Laughter]
forgiving society I can tell you this is
the God's honest truth I've been talking
to a couple teams throughout the whole
process about Delvin cooking one of them
said no you can't take this guy in the
first round I mean this this rattling
off the list of stuff rattling it off
but then all of a sudden what if he's
there in a second course who will be the
Rookie of the Year out of this
offensively and defensively well I'll
tell you what I think Corey Davis has
got a chance I know some people thought
that was a reach for the Titans at five
I thought he was the best receiver in
the draft in I mean there were three run
team so he's going to get nothing but
single coverage
I think Mariota and him were going to be
a nice connection there I think he could
be the Offensive Rookie of the Year and
you know for the Jets
yeah I kind of killed the Jets on air
last night I said they got the worst
roster in the NFL but I got to give it
to him I thought Leonard Williams was
the best defensive player and that draft
it fell in their lap a couple years ago
and I think Jamal Adams with the
second-best player in this year's draft
and fell in their lap at six so I think
he could be the Defensive Player of the
Year
I like Adams I don't know if he can help
change that lock
room there but it feels like he's like
he's a man he reminds me of Rodney
Harrison that he's he's a football
player and somehow someway he's going to
do the right thing but yeah you feel
like it sounds corny damn but what you
feel the guy when he comes in the room
like he's got a real presence about him
what kind of drama do you expect today
well I mean I think you've got some
offensive linemen when you talk about
for celebs and cam Robinson and it's not
a deep offensive line group so I think
you could see some trades here at the
top of the round maybe somebody could
come up and get them and I think we're
going to see Kaiser and Webb go off the
board here pretty quick and I'm
fascinated to find out who those teams
are going to be did the Browns stay with
their strategy and was it a smart
strategy that's why I've been advocating
for them to do all along was and I was
even just saying hey Stan just just stay
right where you are at 1 and 12 don't
even reach for a quarterback just take
and 33 where the other pick was and just
get three good players I mean your
roster is not very good to start filling
in holes with what dudes I thought they
did that and in in joke ooh he was my
12th player game they got him at the
bottom of the first round he's got a
chance to be a special tight end and
Garrett's a freak and then you know
peppers you can be creative and Greg
Williams let's cut him loose have fun
tonight Daniel's great watch last night
with you guys thank you appreciate damn
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience